[Musique]
quand on connaît des gens sales frics là
qui sort mais mon toronto ma cousine et
ma tatie sort avec et en plus tous les
soirs et ne lève pas les doutes tous les
matins non plus et se lavent ne l'a pas
du tout du tout du tout elle quand on me
suit les gens ces images sont idylliques
n'oubliez pas les français sont sales
car ce vraiment crade
la statistique est éloquente ils ne sont
que 25% à se laver tous les jours il
faut savoir qu'il ya en france plus de
télé que de baignoire autre chiffre
30% d'entre eux avouent se laver plus
par nécessité que par plaisir
vous êtes laver les oreilles aussi les
oreilles non présent et non je peux les
voir là dans quel état il ya des risques
que j'avais une otite ya pas longtemps
et je suis contrôleur à la ratp sur les
bus et des fois il ya des odeurs qui se
perdent
ah oui quel genre d'odeurs le mal lavés
et qu'elle prend le métro aux heures
d'affluence vous verrez qu est-ce qui
vous indispose à toutes les odeurs de
transpiration et ses terrasses
épouvantable les gens ne se lave pas
vous allez voir vous en veux vous pouvez
les voir et l'autre des fois quand il ya
des gens qui renifle ça me plaît pas
trop et il ya mon frère aussi des fois
qu'ils en salle
ça change pas tellement d'être propre
mais c'est peut-être ça concerne ça fait
mal à la peau il a pris un bain ou une
douche quand pour la dernière fois
pour la dernière fois c'était dimanche
ça fait quatre jours poche tu te laves
tout le tour des quatre jours
pas forcément parce que je vais à la
piscine à moi elle me dit bon tu vas y
aller sinon tu regardes pas les films
moi je dis mais non c'est trop tard
maintenant je peux pas prendre ma douche
et tout ça j'ai la flemme de l'apprendre
puis je préfère y voir le film dans sa
cause de la terry cap as well as des
fois j'ai la flemme
j'en veux au gaspi les parents avec ça
dans mon temps parce qu'ils font basse
disant vas-y tout de suite parce
qu'après attendons à faire c'est ce
débat obligatoire
bah oui mais pas tout le temps la saleté
ce n'est pas seulement la sphère des
enfants
dans les relations de travail on peut
être aussi incommodé par l'odeur de
londres écoutez ça m'est arrivé de
travailler avec des gens qui avaient une
odeur vraiment très forte mac os moderne
et comme c'était des gens pour qui
j'avais beaucoup d'amitié par ailleurs
puis-je palau je crois que j'ai fini par
en parler mais qu'est ce que vous avez
je sais pas j'avais amené la
conversation sur les déodorants par
exemple bon de choses comme ça bon moi
ce que je faisais toi qu'est ce que tu
fais enfin vous voyez mais s'il vous
rendez compte c'est très difficile à
dire à quelqu'un ça c'est un sujet gêne
encore aujourd'hui l'hygiène bien sûr et
quelle tête vous feriez vous si je vous
disais écoutez je trouve qu'elle bon non
c'est pas possible
ce n'est pas que ça
pas que ça sent pas bon
[Applaudissements]
non non je me suis pas la veine on vous
l'avait pas le matin donnons pas le
matin le soir
non non plus le soir une fois par
semaine non je vous avouerai une chose
là ça fait trente trois jours et 3,44 ça
veut faire trente trois jours et 4
heures que je me porte les mêmes
fringues
pourquoi parce que je me sens bien dans
ses fringues là j'suis pas bon j'ai mon
pantalon quand je le mets il me va bien
mon petit blouson là il est bien
j'ai chaud avec c'est l'hiver je suis
bien comme ça chez en basket j'ai deux
paires de chaussettes pour l'année et
c'est impeccable avec les filles comment
ça se passe avec les filles pour la
drague ces pendaisons
moi je vais vous dire une chose c'est
que bon il ya des filles qui adorent ça
hein
un mec qui est inodore incolore ils
passent pas moi bon quand j'arrive
quelque part
de toute manière que ce soit par l'odeur
ou par n'importe quoi on me remarque on
peut passer à côté de sa toilette
quotidienne
de temps en temps c'est agréable bien
sûr de rester salle de trois jours c'est
possible c'est ça peut faire bâti
d'avoir envie de par exemple garder les
sauteurs de l'autre oui il ya une
certaine séduction dans les odeurs de
l'autre bien sûr puisqu'elle a tout à
fait personnel c'est ce qui vous plaît
dans l'autre c'est son odeur personnel
si son film ans et ça se bâtit sa
sensualité personnelle et vous vous
pourriez rester plusieurs jours sans
toucher aux odeurs sans vous l'avez
peut-être pas plus de trois chez
vous arrivez ne pas vous l'avez de vous
maquiller ça peut arriver
est ce que toi il ya des parties de
temps encore que tu oublie un peu des
deux fois oui quoi valdo ou pas les
pieds puis le dos je vais me laver les
pieds par exemple le dos et la figure
j'aime pas la weser et c'est ce que j'ai
ça fait mal et puis en frais quand par
exemple on sèche les cheveux ça sort ça
fait mal aux tympans
la lame d'un côté les dents elle souvent
j'oublie ma soeur par exemple aller l1 7
ans et elles vont va sur sa brosse à
dent may talent avec un petit peu
d'entreprises parce que ça pique
ils ont honte parce que c'est mieux de
la vie ni bête ni méchants seulement
salle ils ont choisi d'évoluer dans la
crasse et le désordre du linge pas très
net
les lis pas fait ils ne se lavent pas
souvent la salle de bain c'est pas leur
truc
le ménage non plus la vaisselle encore
moins on peut voir là derrière ont
retiré les meubles à laisser ça là qu'il
est bien aussi c'est pas le ménage a été
fait quand la dernière fois le 1er
janvier et pour une femme jeune femme
mètres de là la poussière de la saleté
c'est pas gênant non enfin disons que
c'est sa façon de vivre je veux dire non
c'est pas chez nous enfin moi ça n'a
jamais gêné pour moi ce que je trouve
plus important c'est l'atmosphère qui se
dégage des lieux
c'est bon on s'en tire bien là où on est
puis c'est la relation qu'on a avec la
personne ne fasse est beaucoup plus
important que le paraître à tout prix
quoi à propos d'atmosphère justement
vous allez rire de temps en temps non
sauf que mon père arrive là je suis
obligé c'est contre moi et biarrots
n'ont jamais plus jamais de les nettoyer
car ce n'est pas tout seul avec le lot
de la pluie a par la saleté la ambiante
vous vous l'avez quand même oui votre
dernière douche 7 et qu'en décembre chez
moi en province depuis décembre la
famille la norme le corps sont à 12 juin
vous sentez comment ça contre nous
souhaitons prendre ma dernier 12 3
octobre c'est à dire qu'avant je freud
et mais douchez bon quand je le pouvais
donc je me suis disputé avec lui donc je
peux plus utiliser ces douches mais
disons que disons que bon ben je fais
avec les moyens du bord parce que bon
j'habite à logements là de 48 donc j'ai
qu'un point d'eau c'est un lavabo bon
bah je me lavais avec sa jeune ici parce
existe peut-être tu connais les compare
ils vous font javel réflexion mon copain
non c'est surtout bon ma famille de mon
père quand on accueille ici on dit
toujours c'est ça à quelqu'un qui vous a
déjà dit donc vous sentez pas très bon
il ya ma mère de la première fois j'ai
revu quand je suis arrivé en province
pour des infections tu pues de ne pas
importuner la propreté des autres vous
agace pas disons quand elle commence à
nous nuire aussi pendant deux ans
j'arrive à un endroit propre je respecte
la propreté
mais si une personne arrive dans un
endroit cosy ccr est respecté ma saleté
est ce que tu as des copains et des
copines dans la classe qui sont sales
enfin la speed oui tu en connais qui
semblent pas bon comment ça sans apprêt
après 110 que la pluie les honneurs avec
la de copains des flottilles de copines
qui jane ouais enfin exemplaire de quoi
lâche des gaz
[Rires]
[Musique]